[Musique]
la démission choc de jean philippe panis
lors du mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais une annonce avant-hier soir
des missions choc mais pas franchement
une surprise bonjour jean phi l'orgue
bonjour bonjour à tous les auditeurs
quarante huit heures après cette annonce
souffle-t-il sur vous comme vent de
liberté jean philippe muller non je lui
ont fait dire je considère que 20 de
liberté doit souffler en permanence où
tout un chacun
c'est vrai que c'est une décision que
j'ai pris le temps de mûrir et le fait
de l'annoncer quelque part ça fait du
bien oui parce que les psychanalystes
disent que pour grandir il faut savoir
tuer le père chose faite
non je ne considère pas que j'ai tué le
père je n'ai jamais cherché à tuer le
père si tenté que alfred marie-jeanne
soit mon père je rappelle que mon père
celui à qui je veux ressembler celui qui
m'a transmis toutes les valeurs et qui
m'a donné une éducation c'est s'appelle
serge milon il s'appelle pas un fait
politique a été mon professeur ça a été
un exemple pendant longtemps je n'ai
jamais voulu tuer le père si j'avais
voulu tuer le père bien évidemment je
accepter toutes les propositions qui
m'avaient été faites notamment de me
présenter aux dernières élections dans
ces thèmes je n'ai jamais fait j'ai
refusé de le faire
et malgré tout j'ai aussi toutes les
accusations de complot qui n'ont jamais
été it is à dire ça n'a jamais été
prouvée alors dire que les longues
l'annoncé des équipes parce que j'ai
participé et je ne me suis pas caché
pendant la campagne des pour la septième
d'ailleurs j'ai été désignée tête de
lice quand le sud le sud c'est bien
le secteur géographique de la martinique
qui nous a amené à cette victoire parce
que nous avons mené une campagne
particulièrement active dans le sud et
puis à l'issue des élections
les oies proche de complot de vouloir
trahir le père de coups de couteau dans
le dos sont ressortis je trouve que tout
ça était malsain je n'ai pas voulu que
le p1 et j'ai d'ailleurs c'est triste
mais il en train de se tuer tout cela
actuellement mais je ne vais pas le
laisser tuer le fils non plus et ce
n'est pas parce que quelqu'un vous a
fait du bien et que vous le reconnaissez
que vous devez accepter que cette
personne là vous fasse du mal et sont
les retours depuis cette annonce
avant-hier soir avez vous par exemple eu
des appels de vos collègues de
l'assemblée de martinique oui bien
évidemment j'ai eu beaucoup d'appels de
reconnaître quand même le chef de file
de la majorité dans l'hémicycle
oui ça va changer des choses là
maintenant mais je ne sais rien en tout
cas moi je suis toujours dans avait
compté vos forces au sein de cet
hémicycle
on savait que vous pouvez oui je sais
que je peux conférence est ont jusqu'à
maintenant j'ai toujours pu compter sur
un certainement deux collègues mais les
forces se comptent pas seulement dans
l'hémicycle dans les arènes politique
c'est celle là que ce sera le plus
visible tout de suite mais non non je ne
crois pas je crois que là où les choses
sont le puits le plus fort le plus
puissant c'est dans la population dans
le peuple
et là je peux vous assurer que je compte
beaucoup de soutien il sent bien que je
suppose que la vente la sinne
augmentation c'est que vous êtes
reconnaissants du peuple et l'autre non
non je suis reconnaissant si notamment
de tous les collègues avec qui je
travaille de la majorité comme de
l'opposition
je n'ai pas de difficulté avec ça
précisément dans l'adn du mouvement
politique nous voulons créer
il est à cette idée que nous devons
travailler ensemble et que ce n'est pas
parce que nous nous opposons nous
n'avons pas les mêmes idées surtout que
nous sommes des ennemis
il faut arrêter ces histoires d'ego de
querelles personnelles d'attac
qui en définitive discrédite toute la
classe politique
et c'est en ce sens que le mouvement que
nous avons recueillies ne sera pas un
27e mouvement qui va venir s'adresser à
l'émiettement la balkanisation mais bien
au contraire nous avons intentions et
l'ambition de provoquer vraiment un
déclic au niveau de la classe politique
française concilier avec la politique
faites nous plaisir ce matin comment
s'appellera ce parti jean philippe
miller le connaissais déjà le nom je ne
connais pas un ange audacieux il ya des
propositions qui sont déjà au travail
ont déjà
et d'ailleurs je lance un appel il ya
suffisamment d'intelligence et
d'inventivité et de créativité en
martinique
tout ce que ça m'a déjà dit non non ça
te fait pas pire certains mouvements
patriotiques
vous allez le présenter quand
officiellement on va dire début d'année
ont aidé david âgé certainement janvier
2019 sur quelle base sur quelle
idéologie sur quel socle l'indépendance
de la nation martiniquaise
je ne crois pas que ce soit la question
qu'ils soient à l'ordre du jour
aujourd'hui
den brande you un étendard
d'indépendante soir combien d'années au
mouvement indépendantiste martiniquais
un mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais qui dans les fêtes ne se
bat pas pour indépendants de la partie
nous l'avait déploré
je les développer mais vous y croyez
vous en les défendant faut il faut
admettre aujourd'hui on la défend
n'aurait aujourd'hui ce n'est pas comme
ça que je pose le problème le problème
c'est quoi le problème c'est la
dépendance qui nous mine et le le fait
de dépendre institutionnellement
économiquement financièrement la
dépendance alimentaire la dépendance
environnementale la dépendance peut-être
même intellectuel éducationnel c'est ça
le problème c'est ça le mal de la
martinique les choses grâce à votre jeu
préféré leur me battre aujourd'hui de
manière pragmatique réaliste et plus
moderne pour dire que le combat que nous
menons vise à réduire la dépendance
plutôt que de brandir un étendard
indépendantiste conseiller inaccessible
pour le moment
fait dès lors il ya divorce entre la
population et les politiques de façon
générale car ces politiques ont donné
l'image de personnes déconnecté des
réalités du peuple ne pensant qu'à leurs
intérêts est ce que vous allez y
travailler sur cet aspect bien précis
des choses mais bien évidemment et le
c'est aussi l'une des raisons de ma
démission du mouvement indépendantiste
martiniquais
ainsi le malgache parce que tout le
monde le dilemme a gelé
vous imaginez un mouvement qui se dit
indépendantistes et qui doit être
exemplaire compatriotes qui donne
l'image d'un mouvement qui en train de
se déchirer pour des querelles de
personnes et pour des choses qui ne sont
pas avérés tout simplement parce que il
ya des enjeux des luttes de pouvoir moi
je vais chappert ça moi je veux pouvoir
m'exprimer avec d'autres mais de manière
beaucoup plus sereine marabout qui ne
règle aucun compte précisément je dis
que si j'ai démissionné du mime c'est
pour mettre fin à ce spectacle qui est
lamentable que nous offrons aux
peuplements à la genèse y avait
contribué
il a même roulé mais nous sommes un
exemple tout simple donne un exemple
particulièrement passifs lorsque les
premières gifle sont tombées très
brutalement sur vous mais j'ai en direct
par exemple mais je les ai accepté
j'étais très patient et rédige était
très serein je n'ai jamais cherché du
timbre est finie stations non je
n'aurais je ne le regrette pas
c'est aussi une nouvelle manière de
fonctionner il faut que nous dans tous
les pays qui subit la colonisation
qu'on arrête de mettre l'émotivité en
avant a promis au premier chef
réac réagir sous le sceau de l'émotion
de l'émotionnel ça nous fait quelque
part perdre en lucidité nous devons
précisément aujourd'hui travailler de
manière objective de manière réfléchie
de manière intelligente de manière
apaisée
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir un énervement
à fleur de peau l'énervement
à mon humble avis est plus un signe de
faiblesse que de fond ce vendredi soir
au fini lors il y aura cette assemblée
générale encaisse très par le cabinet a
miroir car le mime et sous
administration provisoire suite à
l'action du groupe de réflexion patriote
vous y serez à l'espace d'aidé ben si
vous êtes présent vous verrez il est
possible que j'y sois jeu dans un
premier temps il est vrai que je pensais
voter par procuration mais je suis en
train d'y réfléchir
peut-être que j'irai moi-même vous poser
mon bulletin vous attendrez vous
attendrez les résultats vous repartirez
avec une poignée de même pour les autres
je ne sais pas en tout cas s'il faut
parti avec une poignée de mais quel que
soit le résultat de cette élection là je
vais partir dans dix villes mais je
souhaite partie avec des poignées de
mains mais peut-être pas pour ceux qui
m'ont trop salie quand même vous
imaginez que j'ai été accusé notamment
d'avoir voulu giflé une collec j'étais
accusé de ça et on a on est allé
raconter ça au président qui sur sa
radio
sans ça que j'ai voulu ce sera dur est
donné une carotte à un collègue un
collègue française en l'occurrence ça
c'est des mensonges et quelque part
c'est des mensonges qui salissent mon
image mais il ya toute une litanie de
mensonges comme ça qui ont été proférées
c'est vrai que ça a été douloureux
pendant un moment aujourd'hui je crois
avoir dit passer tout ça je suis même
prêt à lait tendre la main à ses moteurs
là pour la dernière fois cette assemblée
générale sera l'occasion d'y voir plus
clair dans le fonctionnement de la
gouvernance du mime puisque vous étiez
quand même membre du comité national
le groupe de réflexion patriotes pose
des questions précises sur les comptes
document circule depuis hier une lettre
adressée au cabinet me what des sommes
versées à des candidats pour soixante
dix mille euros des prêts accordés dans
des conditions manifestement flou vous
pouvez nous en dire quelque chose je
prends comme un membre du comité
national
vous êtes au courant de ces produits
bien que je ne participe pas aux
réunions parce que gt commençait manu
quelques mois 2
de transactions qui se serait passé en
2016 2017 2018 si ici a eu ses
transactions là je n'ai pas été informé
bien évidemment et je considère que les
légitimes que les membres d'une
assemblée d'une association pose des
questions pertinentes
ils en ont le droit et la démarche du
groupe de réflexion qu'on appelle
injustement les frondeurs
cette démarche là est tout à fait
légitime et je la soutiens parce que
c'est une démarche pour une exigence de
démocratie et pour que les partis
politiques puissent donner l'exemple aux
peuples au pays
ça doit commencer en interne la
démocratie doit être une priorité une
exigence absolue
on ne peut pas se permettre de biaiser
avec la démocratie sinon ça révèle son
vrai sont sa vraie personnalité en fait
il reste quelques secondes politique
fiction vendredi soir le groupe de
réflexion patriotes obtient la
présidence sur la gouvernance du minfi
vous demande de rester qu'est ce que
vous faites
je parle vous partez comme elle je les
dis je pars quand même j'espère que
d'agir est de récupérer quelques uns
maintenant c'est pas comme ça je suis
pas récupérateur et puis ce n'est pas
cessé autrement que je pose les
problèmes et chaussons sont très
sérieuses beaucoup de militants du
mouvement venant travailler avec nous au
sein de notre mouvement mais aussi
beaucoup de personnes extérieures de dos
on va dire d'obédiences politiques
diverses
ce sera vraiment quelque chose de
nouveau de différent
beaucoup de jeunes martiniquais sur
martinique est prêt à s'engager
en politique dans des conditions
beaucoup plus saine beaucoup d'aînés
beaucoup de domme anticolonialiste de la
première heure sont aussi à mes côtés à
nos côtés pour nous éclairer
comme quoi nous ne nous situons pas du
tout comme ça ça nous a été reproché
dans une lutte être à intergénérationnel
je finis le remercie d'avoir tu ce matin
dans cinq à dix ans c'est beaucoup